news daily from science mission
researchers described a new molecular
mechanism that contributes to
age-related macular degeneration or AMD
in normal retinal cells inflammatory
RNAs are processed but when there is
iron overload RNs gets accumulated due
to the defect in processing leading to
inflammation and AMD next a paper
published in Journal of dietary science
shows that milk protein and its products
from fermentation with lactic acid
bacteria are with sodium caseinate
protected against cardiovascular
diseases in animal models these multi
products decreased LDL and triglyceride
levels possibly by acting on cholesterol
metabolism and by increasing activity of
antioxidant enzymes for more news
visitors at www science mission comma
science mission facebook page news daily
from science mission research as
described in new molecular mechanism
that contributes to age-related macular
degeneration or AMD in normal retinal
cells inflammatory RNAs are process but
when there is iron overload inflammatory
RNAs gets accumulated due to their
defect in processing leading to
inflammation and AMD next a paper
published in the Journal of dietary
science shows that milk protein and its
product from fermentation with lactic
acid bacteria or with sodium caseinate
protected against cardiovascular
diseases in animal models these milk
products decreased LDL and triglyceride
levels possibly by acting on cholesterol
metabolism enzymes and by increasing the
activity of antioxidant enzymes for more
news visitors as www science mission
calm or science mission facebook page
thanks for watching